you wrote an incredible book called
what's our problem a self-help book for
societies
in the beginning you uh present this
view of uh human history as a thousand
page book
where each page is 250 years
and it's a brilliant visualization
because almost nothing happens for most
of it so what blows your mind most about
that visualization we just sit back and
think about it it's a boring book so 950
Pages 95 of the book hunter-gatherer is
kind of doing their thing I'm sure
there's you know there's some there's
obviously some major cognitive
advancements along the way in language
and I'm sure you know the bow and arrow
comes around at some point you know so
so tiny things but it's like oh now a
400 Pages tell the next thing but then
you get to page 950 and things start
moving recorded history starts at 9.76
right right it's basically the bottom
row is when anything interesting happens
there's a bunch of Agriculture for a
while before we know anything about it
and then recorded history starts yeah 25
pages
of actual like recorded history so when
we think of prehistoric we're talking
about pages one through nine seventy
five of the book and then history is
Page you know 976 to 1000. if you were
reading the book it would be like
epilogue a d you know the last little
ten pages of the book and we think of a
d is super long right two thousand years
the Roman Empire 2 000 years ago like
that's so long yeah human history has
been going on for over 2 000 centuries
like that is it's just it's hard to wrap
your head around
um and this is I mean even that's just
the end of a very long road like you
know uh the hundred thousand years
before that it's not like you know it's
not like that was that different so it's
just there's been People Like Us that
have emotions like us that have physical
Sensations like us
um
for for so so long and who who are they
all and what was their life like and
it's you know I think we have no idea
what it was like to be them the the
thing that's craziest about the people
of the far past is not just that they
had different lives they had different
fears they had different dangers and
different responsibilities and they
lived in tribes and everything but they
didn't know anything like we just take
it for granted that we're born on top of
this Tower of knowledge and from the
very beginning we
we know that the Earth is a ball
floating in space um and we know that
we're going to die one day and we know
that
um you know we evolve from animals and
all the those were all like incredible
you know epiphanies quite recently and
the people a long time ago they just had
no idea what was going on and like I'm
kind of jealous because I feel like it
might have been scary to not know what's
going on but it also I feel like would
be you'd have a sense of awe and wonder
all the time and and you don't know
what's gonna happen next and once you
learn you're kind of like oh that's like
it's a little Grim but they probably had
the same capacity for Consciousness to
experience the world
to wander about the world maybe to
construct narratives about the world and
myth and so on
they just had less grounded systematic
facts to play with they've still
probably felt the narratives the myths
they constructed as intensely as we do
oh yeah they also fell in love they also
had friends and they had falling outs
with friends they didn't shower much
though they did not smell nice uh maybe
they did
maybe beauty is in the height of the
beholder yeah maybe it's all like
relative how many people in history have
experienced a hot shower like almost
none that's like when we're hot showers
invented 100 years ago
like less
um so like like George Washington never
had a hot shower it's like it's just
kind of weird like he he took cold
showers all the time or like yeah
um and again we just take this for
granted but that's like an unbelievable
life experience to have a rain a
controlled little booth where it rains
hot water on your head and then you get
out and it's not everywhere it's like
contained
um that was like you know they a lot of
people probably lived and died with
never experiencing hot water maybe they
had a way to heat water over a fire but
like then it's I don't know it's just
like there's a there's so many things
about our lives now that are completely
just total anomaly it makes me wonder
like what is the thing they've noticed
the most I mean the sewage system like
it doesn't smell in cities so
what does the sewer system do I mean it
gets rid of waste efficiently Etc we
don't have to confront it both with our
with any of our senses and that's
probably wasn't there I mean what else
plus all the medical stuff associated
with yeah I mean how about the disease
yeah how about the the Cockroaches and
the rats and the and the disease and the
the plagues and you know and and then
when they got so they they caught more
diseases but then when they caught the
disease they also didn't have treatment
for it so they often would die or they
would just be on in a huge amount of
pain they also didn't know what the
disease was they don't know about
microbes that was this new thing the
idea that these tiny little animals that
are causing these diseases so what did
they think you know in the the Bubonic
plague you know and the the black death
um the 1300s people thought that it was
an act of God because you know God's
angry at us because why would you know
why would you not think that if you
didn't know what it was
um and so the crazy thing is that these
were the same primates so I do know
something about them I know in some
sense what it's like to be them because
I'm a human as well and to know that
this particular primate that I know what
it's like to be experienced such
different things it's and like this
isn't our life is not the life that this
primate has experienced almost ever so
it's just uh it's a bit strange I don't
know I I have a sense that we would get
acclimated very quickly like if we threw
ourselves back a few thousand years ago
it would be very uncomfortable at first
but the whole hot shower thing you'll
get used to it after a year you would
not even like miss it because uh there's
a few uh trying to remember which book
that talks about hiking that Appalachian
Trail
but you kind of miss those hot showers
but I have a sense like after a few
months after a few years well you use
your scale recalibrates yeah yeah I was
saying the other day to a friend that
whatever you used to you start to think
that oh that the people that have more
than me are more fortunate like it just
sounds incredible I would be so happy
but you know that's not true because you
experience what would happen is you
would you would you would get these new
things or you would you would get these
new opportunities and then you would get
used to it and then you would this the
hedonic treadmill you'd come back to
where you are and likewise though
because you think oh my God what if I
had to you know have this kind of job
that I never would want or I had this
kind of marriage that I never would want
you know what if you did you would
adjust and you get used to it and you
might not be that much less happy than
you are now so on the other side of the
you being okay going back you know you
we would survive if we had to go back
um you know we'd have to learn some
skills and but but we would buck up and
you know people have gone to war before
that were in the you know shopkeepers
the year before that they were in the
trenches the next year
but on the other hand if you brought
them here you know I always think it'd
be so fun to just bring forget the
hunter-gatherers bring a 1700s person
here and tour them around take them on
an airplane and show them your phone and
all the things it can do show them the
internet show them the grocery store
imagine taking them to A Whole Foods
likewise I think they would be
completely awestruck and on their knees
crying tears of joy and then they'd get
used to it and they'd be a complaining
about like they don't you don't have
these oranges in stock is like you know
and that's you know the grocery store is
a tough one to get used to like when I
when I first came to this country the uh
the abundance of bananas was the thing
that struck me the most or like
fruits in general but food in general
but banana somehow struck me the most
that you could just eat them as much as
you want that took a long time for me
probably took several years to really
like get get acclimated to that is that
why didn't you have bananas uh the
number of bananas fresh bananas I don't
that that wasn't available bread yes
bananas no
yeah it's like we don't even know what
to have like we don't even know the
proper levels of gratitude yeah you know
walking around the grocery store I don't
know to be like the bread's nice but the
bananas are like we're so lucky I don't
know I'm like oh I could have been the
other way I have no idea well it's
interesting then where we point our
gratitude
in in the west in the United States
probably
we do we point it away from materialist
possessions towards or do we just Aspire
that to do that towards other human
beings that we love because in the East
and the Soviet Union uh growing up poor
is having food is the gratitude
having transportation is gratitude
having warmth and shelters gratitude
and now but see within that the Deep
gratitude is for other human beings it's
the Penguins huddling together for
warmth in the cold I think it's a
person-by-person basis I mean I'm sure
yes of course in the west we will on
average feel gratitude towards different
things or maybe a different level of
gratitude maybe we feel less gratitude
than some than countries that
um you know obviously I think the
easiest the person that's most likely to
feel gratitude is going to be someone
who's on who's whose life happens to be
one where they just move up up
throughout their life a lot of people in
the greatest Generation you know people
who were born in the 20s or whatever and
a lot of the Boomers too the story is
the greatest Generation group dirt poor
and they often ended up middle class and
the Boomers some of them started off
middle class and many of them ended up
quite wealthy and I feel like that life
trajectory
is naturally going to
Foster gratitude right
um because you're not going to take for
granted these things because you didn't
have them
um you know I didn't go out of the
country really in my childhood very much
um you know like you know we traveled
but it was to Virginia to see my
grandparents or Wisconsin to see other
relatives or you know maybe Florida
after going on to the beach and then I
started going out of the country like
crazy in my 20s because I I really you
know became my favorite thing and I feel
like because I if I had grown up always
doing that it would have been another
thing I'm like yeah that's just
something I do but I I still every time
I go to a new country I'm like oh my God
this is so cool and in another country
this thing I've only seen on the map I'm
like I'm there now and so I feel like it
it it's a lot of times it's a product of
what you didn't have and then you
suddenly had but I still think it's Case
by case in that there's a there's like a
meter in in everyone's had you know uh
that I think on on a
at a 10 you are you're experiencing just
immense gratitude right which is a
euphoric feeling it's a great feeling
um and it's
um it makes you happy it's it's to savor
what you have to look down at the
mountain of stuff you have that you're
standing on right to look to look down
at and say oh my God I'm so lucky and
I'm so grateful for this and this and
this and you know obviously that's a
happy exercise now when you move the
meter down to six or seven maybe you
think that sometimes but you're you're
not always thinking that
um uh because you're sometimes looking
up at this cloud of things that you
don't have and the things that they have
but you don't or the things you wished
you had or you thought you were going to
have or whatever and that's the opposite
direction to look right and and that's
the either that's that's Envy that's
yearning
um or often it's it's it's if you think
about your past
um it's it's grievance right and so then
you go into a one and you have someone
who feels like a complete victim they
are just a victim of the Society of the
their their their their siblings and
their parents and their their loved one
um and they are
um they're wallowing in
everything that's happened wrong to me
everything I should have that I don't
everything that has gone wrong for me
and so that's a very unhealthy mentally
unhealthy place to be
um anyone can go there you know there's
an endless list of stuff you can you it
can be aggrieved about and an endless
list of stuff you can have gratitude for
and so it's it's in some ways it's a
choice and it's a habit and maybe it's
part of how we were raised our natural
demeanor but it's such a good act you
are really good at this by the way your
Twitter is like go on well like uh like
you're you you you are constantly just
saying man I'm lucky or like I'm I'm so
grateful for this and that's it's it's a
good thing to do because you're
reminding yourself but you're also
reminding other people to think that way
it's like we are lucky
um you know and um and so anyway I think
that scale can go from one to ten and I
think it's hard to be in 10 I think
you'd be very happy if you could be but
I think trying to be above a five and
looking down at the things you have
more often than you are looking up at
the things you don't or being you know
resentful about the things that people
have wronged you and well the
interesting thing I think was an open
question but I suspect that you can
control that knob for for the individual
like you yourself can choose like the
stoic philosophy you could choose where
you are as a matter of habit like you
said but you can also probably control
that in a scale of a family of a tribe
of us of a nation of a society I mean a
lot you can describe a lot of the things
that happens in Nazi Germany and
different other parts of History through
sort of societal envy and resentment
that builds up maybe certain narratives
pick up and then they infiltrate your
mind and then now your knob goes to from
the gratitude for everything it goes to
resentment and Envy in all Germany
between the two World Wars you know like
like you said the Soviet
um kind of mentality
um so yeah and then when you're soaking
in a culture so there's kind of two
factors right it's
um
it's it's what's going on in your own
head and then what's surrounding you and
what's surrounding you kind of has
concentric circles there's your
immediate
group of people because that group of
people if they're a certain way if they
feel a lot of gratitude and they talk
about it a lot that kind of insulates
you from the broader culture because you
know the the the people are gonna have
the most impact on you are the ones
closest
but often they're all the all the
concentric circles are saying the same
thing the people around you or they're
feeling the same way that the broader
Community which is feeling the same way
as the broader country
um and you know them I think this is why
I think American patriotism
you know nationalism you know can be
tribal can be very not not a good thing
patriotism
um I think is is a great thing because
really what is patriotism I mean it's if
you love your country you should love
your fellow countrymen you know Patriot
you know that's a Reagan quote it's like
patriotism is like I think a feeling of
like
um Unity
um and but it also comes along with an
implicit kind of concept of gratitude
because it's like we are so lucky to
live in you know people you know think
it's chauvinist to say we live in the
best country in the world right and you
know yes when Americans say that no one
likes it right but actually it's not a
bad thing to think it's a nice thing to
think it thinks it's a way of saying I'm
so grateful for all the great things
this country gives to me in this country
has done and and I think you know if you
heard the Philip you know a Filipino
person say you know what the Philippines
is the best country in the world no one
in America would say that's chauvinist
they'd say awesome right because when
you're coming from someone you know
who's not American it sounds totally
fine
um but I think I think you know national
pride is actually good now again that
can quickly translate into xenophobia
nationalism and so you know you have to
make sure it doesn't go off that Cliff
but yeah there's good ways to formulate
that like you talk about we'll talk
about like high wrong progressivism
higher on conservatism those are two
different ways of
of uh embodying patriotism so you could
talk about maybe loving the tradition
that this country stands for or you
could talk about loving the people the
uh that ultimately push progress and
those are
from an intellectual perspective a good
way to represent uh patriotism